tombé ce n'est pas la fin mais le début
est ce que vous connaissez le nombre de
chutes que fait un enfant avant de
savoir marcher 2000
qui dit mieux
huit mille fois lui mille fois avant de
marcher c'est le point commun entre
l'enfant l'entrepreneur et le boxeur et
vous également entreprendre c'est
effectivement essayé tomber se relever
et savoir réagir
ça m'est souvent arrivé ça a commencé à
l'école et sa fille dans les entreprises
que j'ai portée c'est également valable
pour le boxeur sont les défaites en fait
qui vous construisent et qui vous amène
vers la victoire
ce que vous vous posez des questions il
faut trouver les réponses entreprendre
c'est de la créativité
entreprendre c'est de la réactivité
entreprendre c'est également donc se
planter et je me suis souvent planté ça
a commencé à l'école effectivement et
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert en
fait saint denis j'ai été orienté en 4e
techno c'est un dossier où vous le
raconter à personnes sont entre nous
quand je suis arrivé dans ce collège
j'ai fait la rencontre avec j'ai été
percuté par deux choses la boxe thaï et
la culture hip hop la culture hip hop
avec soin c'est un camarade de collège
qui avait 14 ans il avait une maladie il
écrivait son nom partout taguées sur les
murs de l'école dans son quartier sur
les murs de la ville et nuit il a décidé
de frapper plus fort que tout le monde
il s'est introduit dans le dépôt de la
ratp ou ses yeux briller puisqu'il y
avait 30 rames de métro il les a
recouverts à la bombe avec son nom
tranquille 14 ans il a attendu le 1er
mai trois à cinq heures du matin et la
regarder son nom partir jusque châtillon
quelques semaines plus tard il a vu que
la ratp a communiqué sur le nettoyage de
ces rames ça a coûté 5 millions de
francs il a regardé si je m'étais fait
crié papa il aurait dû payer une amende
je me serais fait démonter un mec comme
ça ça vous marque après la 4e techno
j'ai fait la troisième j'ai essayé de
retrouver
seconde générale j'ai raté j'ai fini en
bep j'ai arrêté l'école avec un niveau
bac pro que je n'ai pas eu évidemment je
suis parti travailler comme tout le
monde
un boulot alimentaire quinze ans après
cette 4e techno et quelque part avec des
gens comme semaine j'ai monté un
magazine gratuit avec des amis un
magazine sur la culture hip hop
alors évidemment je n'avais aucune
formation et j'ai commis toutes les
erreurs
inimaginable imaginables excusez moi un
nom imprononçable 5styles facetime
bradés dans la salle il sait ce que
c'est montherme a gagné avec des amis
donc mettre de la fecq dans le
professionnel c'est une erreur fatale
ça finit en divorce et puis vendre de la
pub appelé les annonceurs et limite les
agresser parce qu'on n'a pas structuré
son discours donc voilà j'ai fait mon
stage de quelques années et huit ans
après tout ça je suis devenu prêtre
patron presse les trouver des solutions
à chaque fois que je me plantais et au
moment où c'était ça commence à être
stable
j'ai suivi deux nouveaux échecs
enfin cette fois ce n'était pas de ma
faute j'ai été formé il ya eu la crise
du disque donc moins de budget de
nouveaux concurrents
la presse papier qu'elle est mal et
l'arrivée des sites internet et mon
associé qui a décidé de monter un
magazine concurrent normal il est parti
puis quelques années l'adresse allez hop
on se fait la guerre tout ça j'ai réussi
à l'affronter j'ai même eu un prix avec
la chambre de commerce espoirs de
l'économie la chambre de commerce de
paris et j'ai dû trouver de nouvelles
solutions face à ses difficultés
alors j'ai repensé à cette idée de
culture hip hop cette notion d'utiliser
la ville comme support le modèle
économique pour le magazine qui était
gratuit
c'était la vente des espaces
publicitaires et je me suis dit vu que
ça devient difficile
comment étendre ça
j'ai trouvé un nouveau modèle économique
j'ai sorti la pub du magazine les
utilisaient la ville comme support de
communication
en fait c'est le street marketing je
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu ça c'est
des des affiches cartonné à graffer sur
les poteaux des gens qui diffusent de
l'information
la projection sur les murs de la ville
de bandes annonces pour des films et
donc développer ça ça marchait plutôt
bien c'est assez drôle en rendez vous
parce que quand je démarre chez les
prospects
j'arrivais évidemment votre
interlocuteur vous demande vos
références
je lui disais que mes références arrêté
dans la rue on ne regardait bizarrement
les équipes qui raconte sur lui disait
vous avez l'affichage de prins oui c'est
nous vous avez vu la campagne de bénabar
oui c'est nous la vida loca le film oui
c'est nous et donc du coup j'avais un
slogan nos références sont dans la rue
et j'ai trouvé un nouvel équilibre
puis vint lite l'été 2010 où j'avais su
est tellement d'échec que je me sentais
fort je me prenais pour un ironman un
petit peu mais j'avais un problème
un nouveau problème un problème plus
profond que les obstacles que j'avais pu
rencontrer c'est de me dire est ce que
je faisais quelque chose qui me plaisait
et la réponse était non c'était non à
part une rubrique dans le magazine parce
que je vous ai pas parlé de l'aspect
éditorial
j'avais une rubrique s'appelait mec à
l'ancienne c'était mieux avant dans
cette rubrique qui faisait une double
page je racontais tous les dossiers mon
adolescence et je prenais beaucoup de
plaisir a raconté la grosse coupe de
cheveux ce que la mère voulait pas payer
le coiffeur donc j'étais obligé
d'assumer six mois avec une grosse coupe
et on se faisait chambrer à l'école avec
mes frères vous appelez les frères
mireille mathieu c'est dur il y avait
aussi l'époque des frites famille modèle
c'était difficile on manger des frites
matin midi et soir c'est véridique et ça
aussi ça fait partie des super souvenirs
et cette rubrique en fait j'ai kiffé ce
qui fait écrire je kiffe avoir des gens
de ma génération qui me faisait un
retour là dessus et c'est vrai que
l'écriture en fait ça me parle et je me
suis levé un matin
j'ai vu mon associé je suis dit arrête
le magazine j'arrête tout madame est du
kenya était tombé en vélo qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu dis non ça me plaît plus on
a discuté et j'ai décidé en fait de
partir vers l'écriture
à cette époque-là sur canal+ il y avait
deux nouvelles séries qui émergeait
braquo engrenage la commune avec des
personnages qu'il y avait des dialogues
et je me sentais capable de fabriquer
ses personnages et c'est vers ça en fait
que je voulais aller pour aller vers ça
évidemment ayant eu l'expérience du
magazine j'avais je n'avais jamais
travaillé dans ce métier je me suis dis
pas je vais utiliser cette histoire de
cv vous avez amené mes références dans
la rue balaj allait amener mon cv dans
la rue et donc j'ai rencontré un éditeur
indépendant on a travaillé ensemble sur
cette histoire
le titre s'était les anges s'habillent
en caillera et quand on a fini l'aspect
écriture je lui ai dit on va faire
d'affichage en faire çà çà çà çà il me
regarde oui c'est ça oui oui c'est ça et
finalement un mois de la sortie du livre
je me suis mis en mode batman encore
référence de super héros et je sortais
la nuit avec trois mille affiches et 100
livres de colle et géré papy c'est tout
le 93 2,93 à son premier roman noir les
anges s'habillent en caillera
et je peux vous dire que trois jours
après la sortie à une rupture de stock
les hydrater oui c'est ça rachid c'est
ça et donc j'ai eu aussi des retombées
de ce que j'ai des boîtes de prod qui
m'ont contacté et j'ai commencé à avoir
un pied dans ce que je voulais faire
alors tout à l'heure on a parlé de la
dictée des cités le concept était
finalement de ramener la littérature
dans la rue autour de ça autour de ce
que j'avais envie de faire
j'ai décliné pas mal de choses me suis
retrouvé à intervenir dans des
établissements scolaires dans des
maisons d'arrêt auprès des chefs
d'entreprises autour de l'écriture et de
tout ce qu'ils avaient et je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait un auteur ne
pouvait pas être simplement quelqu'un
qui avait envie d'écrire des livres ou
des scénarios mais qu'avec la
littérature je pouvais aussi être
acteurs du territoire
et c'est comme ça j'ai continué à écrire
des romans l'année dernière j'ai écrit
quatre scénarios et surtout il avait ce
projet de la dictée des cités finalement
c'était sortir la dictée hors des murs
de l'école est de ramener des publics
qui se retrouvent tous autour de cette
dictée les seniors c'était facile parce
que c'était des fans de pivot mais pour
les plus petits
leur faire une dictée sur un texte de
zola ou de victor hugo c'est peut-être
plus compliqué donc on a mis ça en place
et aujourd'hui c'est ce que je veux ce
que je vous ai raconté
c'est que finalement quand on sait ne
sait ce n'est que le début de quelque
chose d'une longue aventure et de votre
entreprise votre entreprise elle peut
être personnel peut être professionnel
et donc faut savoir toujours se relever
quand on je vous remercie